Thinking with, thinking, thinking with, thinking with, thinking with, yeah, yeah, you're gonna feast on this one.
Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought.
That's what it is, that's what it is, that's what it is.
The internal structure of book, as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from the subject.
Thinking with, thinking, thinking with, thinking with, thinking with.
We're back for part two of book five of Nietzsche's Gay Science.
This is the 12th episode we're recording on this one, and my God, it's been a journey.
Well, this has been like a two-year season.
Oh, I know.
So we've kind of gone off the rails a bit, but our fans will be, our fans will be happy to know that we're coming back after a literally almost two-year hiatus.
I love that we have fans.
Our 25 fans.
Just building tension, that's all we're doing.
Oh, is that what it is?
Yeah.
I thought we were losing listeners.
It's not just laziness and incompetence, it's actual marketing.
Well, do we want to talk about what's next?
No.
What's, what's, let's, let's, let's gay science it up, and then we'll figure out what's next.
Let's gay things up, and then we'll.
I feel like we haven't talked in a long time, so let's just sprinkle in the small talk.
I feel like we got it.
There's a whole lot of basketball things.
There are topics that need to be, need to be addressed.
Yeah.
That need to be discussed.
Yes.
No, putting my foot down.
We're talking Nietzsche right now.
This is going to happen.
Nietzsche's going to happen.
We can do basketball afterward.
Okay, we've been doing this for a long time, and I, it's in some ways not surprising, almost
necessary that, that we've done the gay science over some of like really difficult parts of
our lives, and that we've had to, you know, I mean, I think we've mentioned this a couple of times,
but between my separation and move, and Nate moving to like a starting out completely different job,
and we'll just call it John's life, you know, there's been a kind of perpetual disarray.
There's been a sort of a continued need to just find some kind of joy in taking this up as a philosophy of, of, of life.
And since December 15th, I was on strike for 22 days.
That's right.
And not metaphorically, you were on actual strike.
No, we were on actual strike from February 12 to March 5, and it sort of all arose from, you know, just like just completely avoidable stuff.
Like, you know, it's nothing crazy was going on in the negotiating process other than the simple desire for, you know, the employer to somehow just try to put us in our place.
And it required 22 days to get a reasonable deal.
And I discovered a couple of things about myself that have making it really exciting to come back to, to Nietzsche's.
A, I'm at my happiest when I'm playing with complexity and nuance.
B, when put to it, like say going on strike, I'm just a, a stupid reductive Marxist.
It's just like, there's, there's this one truth to the world.
The history of the world can be understood as class struggle.
And your only job is to, to find the bigger stone and throw it back.
And that gave me an incredible amount of, of, um, energy for, for a while.
And we can turn and talk about the, you know, the, the sort of energy that faith gives for the, the weakened soul.
We'll come back to that for a second because the other thing I discovered is that you do that for long.
And I mean, like you do that for more than five days and you, you're poisoned there.
They're like, I could just feel a poisoning of my soul.
I'm just angry all of the time.
I go to bed angry.
I wake up angry every single bit of communication.
I mean, I found an incredible generosity and, and, and a, um, compassion for most people because they're on the side of the laborer against that they're on my side.
Right.
It gave me an incredible sort of like compassion and generosity and flexibility for, you know, the plight of, of the worker against the evil of capital.
But it just, it wore me down just really, really quickly.
And it took me a long time to recover.
So the idea of coming back to this and trying to find a little bit of complexity of levity of is, is then, well, it's, I, I desperately need it.
That's, that's where I'm at, but help me find the joy.
Well, he talks a lot about like health.
I forget the exact term he uses, but like we're after some sort of good health as, as thinkers and as people.
I'm similarly, I haven't gone through anything like that with administration, but it's been a bit of a rough semester, uh, just physically health wise.
And I mean, this is all the rage now, but the whole connection between, um, you know, mind and body and gut health and brain health, all that shit is sort of taken for granted.
I think these days, but, um, it couldn't have been more true this semester.
Uh, just because I can't work out.
I don't want to bore us with all the details, but I have too many like micro injuries and I can't do any of the things that I would normally do that would bring me joy outside of thinking and learning.
Um, so it was actually kind of a, it was like a jolt to read some Nietzsche again, cause I just haven't been in that, um, that mindset.
It was pretty refreshing this morning.
Once one has trained one's eye to recognize in a scholarly book, the scholar's intellectual idiosyncrasy.
Every scholar has one and catch it in the act.
One will almost, uh, always find behind it, uh, the scholar's prehistory, his family, especially its occupations and crafts.
Is that the scholarly book one?
Yeah, this is, uh, 348 on the origins of the scholar and then 349 once again.
Oh, I was, okay.
I was, I'm at 366, the faced with the scholarly book.
Yeah.
I mean, there's kind of several of them that sort of.
Cause the one for, the one for me that, I mean, I guess it, I mean, it speaks to sort of various life circumstances, but the romanticism question, um, towards the, towards the end, it's section 370.
What is romanticism?
And this is where he makes a basic distinction, which he makes in other places.
I mean, he just spends more time on it here, but, um, there are two, there are two kinds of, this is, it's, um, on page 328, what is romanticism?
Every art, every philosophy may be viewed as a remedy and an aid in the service of growing and struggling life.
I mean, this is basic Nietzsche, right?
Like, you know, all, all art, all life, it's an expression of will to power, right?
For, for a particular form, form of life.
Um, they always presuppose suffering and sufferers.
And then this is it.
But there are two kinds, there are two kinds of sufferers.
First, those who suffer from the over fullness of life.
They want to die in ice in art and a tragic view of life, a tragic insight.
And those who suffer from the impoverishment of life, who seek rest, stillness, calm seas, redemption through art, et cetera, et cetera.
And the whole rest of that section goes on to, to discuss like that basic difference, right?
And it's the, and he links it to the difference between being and becoming.
And, um, you know, the, the, the, um, and, and for me, it's like, it's, it's very clear to, to me in terms of suffering that the impoverishment of life is like, I want rest.
I want, I want, I want to, I want to break.
Like, I'm not on the good Dionysian team, you know, um, I just like quiet it down, calm everything down.
Like that sort of desire for, for less stimulation.
Um, and, and, and it's, it is, it's just, it's a, it's a phase, it's also a phase of life, right?
Like there you go through certain types of, um, negative times that, that can, that feel different than other kinds of negative times.
Like what, what you're talking about, I mean, Nathaniel, I mean, I'm familiar with that where it's like times where I just, I grow to sort of, uh, uh, hate the institution.
I, I think of all of the passages in which Nietzsche says things like the strong need to be protected from the weak.
And it's precisely because of the poison of resentment and the ways in which you can, you can, um, you know, even if you are this sort of overabundance of life, you can get sucked into this sort of, you know, uh, weariness and exhaustion, uh, with life very, very easily, you know?
And, and, and that's the, in Zarathustra, it's like, that's one of the stages of his convalescence, you know, is just the, the disgust with, you know, management or whatever you want to call the capital or whatever it is, where it's just like, this is so gross to have to deal with.
And it just makes you feel so gross and every, and it infects every part of your life.
And it, it, it works a whole lot.
I mean, we can jump into some of the religion stuff a little bit later, but it's interesting in that, like one of the, you know, effectively, he says somewhere here that what, what's one of the major things that religion provides is it's, uh, the tracing of the familiar, like the unfamiliar to the familiar or the, or being provided certainty in the face of uncertainty.
And, you know, I mean, the, the sense of anger that I had, that sense of like resentment, we can talk all about sort of like the consciousness-building function of resentment is, but is that I never feel so thoroughly distinguished as an individual, as an individual conscience, uh, as when I'm angry like that.
Is there just a clear boundary between what counts as me, what counts as us, what counts as them and the, the entire sort of like moral machinery that distinguishes us.
Like you did X to, yeah.
Judgments.
Uh, like, you know, you did X to us.
That was shitty.
Now you're going to pay for it.
And it is, wears you down.
Well, but more often than not, I mean, what Nietzsche is saying, and I mean, this is really Hegel too, is that subjectivity is built by opposition.
I mean, that's sort of, that's where it thrives.
Yeah.
That's its, that's its environment.
And I mean, the Nietzsche's spin on it is that this is poisonous.
Right.
It was like, so, but I think also his point is also like you read in here, we can't be Dionysus all the time.
I mean, everybody falls into resentment.
Oh yeah.
Probably pretty frequently.
Yep.
You know, so it's about rebuilding back towards that Dionysian.
Well, and it can be the physical health thing too.
I mean, that's what I like about the, the two anecdotes that you guys both, you know, began with, with, you know, one is a occupational situation and the way that that induces, you know, that, that intensity of the anger.
But the other is, you know, a physical situation where you're just unable to do, uh, the kind of active things that are, that are sort of necessary.
I mean, we have the passages in here, I mean, that are in Ecce Homo.
And I think that's what I like about the, you know, in other places as well, where it's like the necessity of activity.
You know, what, what's the, the question?
He's like, the question that I ask of any book is like, does it, does, does the book dance?
Um, and, and, and it's so nice to put down books that don't like with a sense of relief.
I think this is one of the, it's, uh, the moments in the scholarly thing where he, and he's saying like most scholarship is oppressed, right?
Marked by oppression.
Our first question about the value of a book, a human being, or a musical composition is, can they walk, but even more, can they dance?
We read rarely, but worse on that account, how quickly we guess how someone has come to his ideas, whether it was while sitting in front of an inkwell with a pinched belly, cramped intestines, et cetera, et cetera.
Every scholarly book mirrors a soul that has become crooked.
Every craft makes crooked, right?
Like there's, I mean, that, that sense of activity.
So my, my question, my question is why, why the metaphorics of dance?
Because I, I think I, I know what he's after.
I know the kind of what the, what the terms loaded with activity, movement, improvisation.
Lightness.
But for some reason, lightness, lightness on the feet.
Yeah.
So I, I think I understand what he's after, um, when he employs that word, but there's a little bit of resistance on my end.
Like, is there another term for it that would be equally as, cause he, that's, he comes back again and again to dance.
Yeah.
And I just find like, at least in a contemporary context, dance just sounds a little silly.
Like in, in terms of like an ethic or something.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Well, I mean, cause it's, it's being distinguished in relationship to, to finding up a place of
Seriousness.
Yes.
I guess.
Yeah.
Heaviness for sure.
Seriousness, gravity, you know.
But also in terms of like marking out a space, like the, the, the sort of function of morality of, of drawing the boundary line and saying on this side is the good team.
And on that side is the bad team.
And then now that we have that sense of certainty, that sense of familiarity, now we can sort of go about the duty of life and just simply play it out.
But, but the, but the dancing is constantly remaking the terrain.
Right.
My, I guess my, my hesitance is just cause like dance as a profession seems just sort of a little bit frivolous to me.
And it also seems, frivolous is good.
Yeah.
Frivolous is sure.
But it also, I mean, maybe I'm just thinking about it wrongly, but dance doesn't seem to imply the creativity.
Obviously Nietzsche is also invested in music, but to me, music is about more than dancing.
So like I get, I feel like there's, it doesn't imply the creativity that's loaded into his project as much as just the term music does.
Like dance and music aren't, I don't know.
I feel like music encompasses more than just the dance.
Yeah, music is, I agree with you.
But I think dance, my sense of the primary emphasis of dance is the lightness and it's the non, it's the anti-gravity.
Like you're, you're jumping.
Yeah.
Right.
But I think it's also the perpetual self-creation is that, you know, I mean, I think about, you know, one sense of music as sort of like, you know, reading, repeating the notes on the composition in the form of music.
And then think about something more in terms of improvisation or jazz, where the, like, you could say that the music dances with itself, like jazz dances with itself in that it's constantly recreating its own terrain and finding new lines of flight.
So it, it has its own mechanism of self-overcoming built into it rather than finding a sedentary point against its opposition.
And then when it does change, it's changed because it's failed in its totalization relationship to, you know, the opposite, right?
Dance is self-overcoming in a way that, that, um, at least some ways of thinking of music is not like you could say that he likes music, but the dancing kind of music.
Yeah.
Well, we don't have to get into all the peculiarities, but like, I wonder if for him, like, did Wagner dance for him before?
Because obviously he has this, like, uh, transformative interpretation of Wagner.
Wagner, yeah, but, but he, but Wagner's like heavy for him though.
Yeah, that's, I mean, that's the, the, the, the sort of turning point is, I mean, I think when he was young at one point he saw, he saw Wagner's music as.
Triumphant.
Orienting to, yeah, orienting towards his triumph, but it, but then it became about the individual artist and how great I am.
Um, and, and that was disappointing.
And then like Parsifal, like this sort of country bumpkin figure, like the Forrest Gump basically, uh, figures like, wait, wait, wait, what happened to the sort of heroic, uh, tragic, the sense of the heroic and tragic seemed to disappear.
Um, and it became, um, you know, that's by root when they set, when the fest there, they created this festival that was all about Wagner and adoration of Wagner.
And Nietzsche was like, this is gross.
You know?
Yeah, he, obviously music was important, but I, I do think that dance, um, cause the, if you're, if you're honest about it, you'd have to say just like what he just, the part that I read you about suffering there is like, there's a dance from overabundance and there's a dance from exhaustion.
Right.
Like there's, you know, if, if, if you're going to take dance itself as the object, there are different ways of dancing.
Um, but the, obviously it seems to me that the sense of dance that he's interested in is that, that sort of, again, the lightness and the abundance of like, I don't give a fuck.
Nothing matters.
You know, there's no consequences.
Um, the Dionysian is linked to the dance.
Well, and so the style of this book must be the most danceable out of any, almost any of his works then with the, with the aphorism, with the quickness with which he attacks these.
I mean, he talks about it towards the end, I think of book five about sort of justifying the style a bit.
Um, but it's, you know, that it's not, it's not lacking something because he's quickly moving between different conceptual terrain that that's actually something to try to cultivate.
It's the positive quality that he's, yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
So it's not a scholarly book.
Like he clearly doesn't think of himself as a scholar, right?
Like, and honestly, this is how the style book that I have been not writing for a decade.
Um, like that's how I think of the style book.
Like, I mean, it's, it's scholarly relative to, you know, most fucking New York Times bestseller things, but it's not a scholar.
It's not scholar.
I mean, you guys have read some of, some of the chunks of that.
It's not scholarly in the sense of like making some sustained argument or investigation of documents or anything like that.
It's just like vignettes of thoughts, you know?
So that's how I very much think of that.
I mean, I don't think of it in terms of dancing per se, but I do think of it as like, as light.
In other words, I'm intentionally not sustaining an argument.
It's not because I forgot that we were supposed to do that.
Yeah.
Back when I was working on the, the book project or the article or whatever, which Nathaniel and I did a couple, um, like collaborative sessions on, like, I feel like there's just, especially as a, a newcomer in the field, I feel like there's a lot of pressure to adhere to at least some version of, of scholarly traditionalism.
But, but the, our field tends to encourage experimentation, at least in certain pockets.
That's right.
You know, so it's, it's difficult for me to embrace that transdisciplinary experimentation while at the same time feeling like, let me get something on the table.
That's digestible to status quo.
I mean, you're, you're right.
And, and it's a, it's a time of career thing.
Like I, when I, I mean, it was like four years ago for me when I hit upon the idea, I think I actually feel like it was Nathaniel's idea.
I can't remember.
But like there was, but there was a point where it was like, why do you have to write chapters?
And it was, it was like, I had literally not had that thought before and chapters in the sense of like a 20, 20 to 25 page sort of sustained.
And it's like, oh, I could just write six to 10 page, you know, vignettes.
And that was incredibly, I was like, wow, that works so much better for, you know, everything that I want to do.
And, but I mean, and like, I'm a relatively smart guy, but that thought had just never occurred to me because I was so, I mean, I was so, I had so cultivated the essay, right?
Well, essay in the academic sense, not essay in the historical sense, right?
And so, you know, that, that was, that was hugely liberating because it was like, oh my God, there's a fucking genre here that, and it's not like it's, I mean, it's not like it's sort of ludic.
I don't think, you know, I think that it's just a different kind of rigor, but it's one that, you know, when, what, how many scholarly, how many books by people in our field have structures like that?
Like, not that I can think of.
I mean, I, I, maybe, maybe there is one or two, but I don't know.
And it's not by the theory folks, you know?
No, and I mean, you're right.
It's totally a career thing because there's just, I mean, Nate, you doing something like that, there's an incredible risk to it.
That if what you do isn't recognizable to someone else, then you're messing with the possibility of tenure, right?
Whereas, like, John can do this, and even if nobody gives a shit, his job isn't threatened.
Right, my job's not in jeopardy, right.
So, like, yeah, your first book, just do your book and get the contract and get that fucking thing out there.
Then you can, then you can experiment with other things because it doesn't matter after that.
And, right.
I mean, that really is, like, in some ways.
That's the point, that's the point of tenure, right?
Like, is, is precisely, like, use tenure.
I mean, I'm going to spin that the other direction is that, you know, what it actually does is facilitate something far more interesting to happen.
And not, not that it doesn't, I mean, it doesn't matter in the best of all possible ways and that you're not straightjacketed by, you know, that fear of, of not getting tenure of, by, by the form of the four or five chapter book, whatever it is.
That, that, that it can open up lines of thinking that weren't otherwise available because, I mean, like, to go back to your style book, John, it's not like any of those, any of those vignettes are not recognizable as scholarly intellectual arguments.
Every one of them is, is that, but the major advantage of it is that you're able to, and I think, you know, like, The Logic of Sense and A Thousand Plateaus is that you're able to come at a, a, a relatively narrow set of questions from, like, three or four times the number of angles that you would otherwise be afforded to it.
And they can, they don't have to be all cut from the exact same sort of theoretical fabric.
That's right.
They don't have to line up perfectly.
Right, right.
And, and, you know, if there was one thing that I've learned from Deleuze and Nietzsche is the nuanced sense producing power of what we would often call paradox.
And do you like, you know, actually finding intersecting lines rather than, you know, like coherent subordinate lines can just provide so much more precision.
But I, but I, but I do, but I still, I mean, I, I hear you like there is, I mean, I remember that phase of my career where it was like, you know, I think I had more of an experimental sensibility when I was in grad school and it kind of got.
Not intentionally, but it kind of just got trained out of me because I spent so much time trying to learn how to write an academic article and then an academic book.
And so I just lost that.
I mean, I go back and read some of the stuff that I wrote in graduate school.
If, or if I think back about them, like they were some weird experimental things, you know?
Yeah.
Structural.
Well, like you're writing the virus thing.
Right, exactly.
That's an example, you know?
But you didn't do that in graduate school.
That's super, but it's super weird.
Yeah, I did.
I think I did.
Didn't I?
You did that for a theory conference, I thought.
No, but I think I took it, I took from a something, a chunk of something that I had written in graduate school and then, you know, refashioned it.
Ah, fascinating.
Right.
Well, that kind of structural or stylistic experimentation, that's what seems to be rare.
I feel like with content, our field is like, hey, let's talk about anything that we want at this point.
Like we've opened the floodgates in terms of talking about different content.
I think there's some, a little bit of leeway in terms of conceptual experimentation, like the fact that we have a theory wing of the field.
The fact that Diane Davis can have a career writing those sorts of weird texts.
But the kinds of experimentation that she did in breaking up a totality versus the rest of the field.
Right, that's right.
Like in terms of, stylistically, it's pretty homogenous.
Yeah.
Still.
It feels like.
But I don't know.
I don't think you have to be structurally innovative to come up with an experiment.
Like you can be, you can be experimental just in syntax in a formal essay.
For sure.
As well.
Like there's all different types of experimentation.
For sure.
In fact, like I feel like something like Derrida's, glaw, like with the two sides, like to me, that just annoys me.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm just like, give me one thing.
It's too performance art.
It's too like, look at me.
I'm experimenting.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I agree with that.
Like I've, that's why I've always liked, you know, like Hollywood movies that are smart as opposed to art films who scream, I'm smart, think about me.
So, yeah, I mean, and that's a taste preference.
I share that with you.
Nonetheless, it would be cool to write something in the style of The Gay Science or something more aphoristic and have it published under the umbrella of like in our field.
Something that, you know, got some momentum in our field that was written this way.
Yeah.
I mean, we've talked about this before.
You can't even really, you can't write like Deleuze.
You can't write like Derrida necessarily and get published easily.
Yeah.
We'll see.
I mean, that's, that's the gambit.
Well, I don't, somebody needs to pave the way.
Somebody, I mean, if you get published with that book, maybe that would sort of be, maybe you'd be a trendsetter.
Because I think you were that with the post-humanism as well.
Yeah, yeah.
At least with the, with the sort of historical work that I've been doing.
You were the, I think the first person to use the term.
I think we were the first.
You and Debbie.
I think me and Debbie.
Yeah.
I think that thing that we did back in, I wish that I'd, I wish I'd hung on to that term in, in, in the invention book rather than post, rather than going to post-modernism.
Because that was like the last death throw of post-modern, like nobody uses the word post-modernism anymore, you know.
Was that a, that was a choice to, to commit to post-modernism?
Because you could have gone.
I could have.
It's just at the time, there's still.
Would have taken more work.
Yeah, it was, and post-humanism wasn't a, wasn't really a word that circulated.
I mean, when Debbie and I used it at that point, there was literally like two things in print that used the word post-humanism, you know, like.
So there would have been no reference.
There was nothing.
Nobody had any idea what you meant about post-humanism.
Carrie Wolfe had written his book.
This is, Catherine Hales had written her book.
The becoming whatever, why, how have we become post-human or something like that.
So that was Catherine Hales.
And she's totally lit person, you know, lit and science, science studies-y person.
And then there was one other, I can't even remember what it was.
There's one other thing.
But that's why, that's where we pulled that term from.
And, because it was a sort of science studies-y.
But now it's ubiquitous, right?
Well, now it's the point of departure as opposed to post-modernism.
That's right.
Now you have to, I mean, at least in rhetorical theory, you have to react to post-humanism.
Or new materialism.
New materialism or whatever.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, that's totally right.
Yeah.
And post-modernism is just, I mean, who even uses the word anymore, you know?
Nobody, really.
Yeah.
But should we tie, I mean, should we, should we, Nietzsche as a post-humanist?
Have people really, I mean, I think Debbie's done a bit with that.
Yeah, I teach it, I mean, I teach him as the, I mean, like, my undergrad class, yeah, my undergrad class, it was like, here's humanism, and we do the, we do some renaissance humanism.
Pico de la Mirandola's Oration on the Dignity of Man, and that's great, because it really, concretely in five pages, teaches you humanism.
It's about freedom and choice, you know, it's totally, like, liberal humanism.
Right.
And then I teach that in conjunction with Nietzsche, where he, you know, the beginning of Truth and Lies, where it's just like, oh, yeah, learning stuff is really so cool.
And I just teach it as anti-human, I mean, I'm not trying to nuance it for them at all, I just teach this as humanism, anti-humanism, you know?
And then I teach that with Althusser as well, so Althusser will give the Marxist anti-humanist version.
That sounds like a good class, man.
I should be a teacher.
It does feel like Nietzsche's post-humanism is unique.
I mean, insofar as his philosophy can be categorized that way.
Well, look, I mean, I, the, for me, the reason why I have all these years stayed on the Nietzsche train,
I mean, they're, you know, other than that it's, like, sort of built into my soul at this point,
but, like, is, is entirely that, like, over, the overcoming of the human is the project.
That's it.
That's the project.
Of the human.
Yes.
The overcoming of the human is the project.
And so, now, what that means is, is up for grabs, but he's, he's the first person to say, like,
here's the point of, here's the point of thinking, to overcome the human, right?
Here's the goal, here's what should be the goal of every life, to overcome the human.
You know, I mean, it's just so straightforward, and so you can't, I mean, I can't think of
another thinker in the 19th century who saw overcoming the human as the goal.
And that, I mean, that's not, it's not, he doesn't mean, like, necessarily the destruction
of, of human being.
Right.
That's an important, that's right.
I mean.
It's not genocide.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean, if you could specify it, though, like, it would be some version of overcoming
resentment.
Right.
But to me, the, the term would be subjectivity.
Like, it's, it's a little more limited.
Like, there's a version of human being that is driven by subjectivity.
Right.
And that's everybody, unfortunately.
But that particular mobilization of the way that we relate to ourselves and to the world,
that is what's become parasitic and, and problematic.
This is, think of Foucault, the end of the, end of the order of things.
If, if you haven't read, if you haven't read that, you totally should.
But it's about man as being a face on the sand of recent invention or humanity.
And like, that, that face is going to get washed away.
And it's exactly, it's saying exactly what you are, which is, this is not about destroying
bodies.
Right.
It's about creating different kinds of sensibilities, but it's also not void of bodies
either.
Right.
It's not, it's not an idea.
It's not, you know, so humanism, isn't just a series of ideas.
They are in core, you know, incorporated ideas.
They are ways of life that are, that are material and corporeal as well.
So that's the hard thing is you don't want to just end up on the side of like the idealists
and say like, Hey, we just want to change people's minds.
It's like, no, we want to change their bodies too.
Right.
Like that's part of the, part of the project of the, the people who call themselves transhumanists,
for instance.
Right.
Like, or, or cyborgs now, like there's tons of these folks who are doing weird shit with
their bodies and brains and hooking technology up into them.
And then to me, that's, that's of a piece, right?
It's of a piece with other kinds of experiments that are about sort of producing a mode of response
that isn't reliant on resentment, for instance.
So much of it too, for me, I think of it as, um, emblematic of the antagonism between thinking
and, and the, the function of the, like the category of the concepts as like the, the, the
function of the concept of the human is something that yes, is an idea, but also then has such
material cultural, uh, um, imports.
And like, I mean, you know, the, the, the, there's such a delicate antagonism between the
category, the concept and thinking, which thinking cannot eschew.
It can't get rid of it, but it's also the, like the more firmly defined the human is as
a concept is the less opportunity there is for, for thinking.
Yeah.
Well, and Nietzsche does well in the second half of this section to emphasize how embodied
thinking actually is.
It's like the, all the emphasis on affect, the libidinal quality to, to philosophy and the
whole problem with, um, idealism and I guess scholarship in general is that, I mean, he calls
it bloodless, that it's so detached from its material conditions of emergence, um, that it's
constantly fleeing from those conditions that like wisdom is equated with lifeless.
This bloodless reflection on a reality that's no longer, yeah.
This is this, this is 372, why we are not idealists.
And also 351 in honor of the priestly type.
Well, you do that one and then we'll do 372.
Fucking show off.
I'll just read the first half of it.
Um, all right.
In honor of the priestly type, I think that what the people mean by wisdom and who today
is not people, that prudent cow-like serenity, piety and country parson meekness, which lies
in the meadow and earnestly and ruminantly observes life is also that from which precisely the philosophers
have always felt the most remote, probably because they were not people enough, not country parsons
enough.
They will presumably also be the last to learn to believe that, uh, that people might come
to understand something of that, which is most remote from them.
Something of the great passion of the knowledge seeker who steadfastly lives and must live in
the thundercloud of the highest problems and the weightiest responsibilities.
And thus in no way as an observer outside and different secure, uh., objective, the people
venerates quite another type of person when they construct for themselves an ideal of the
sage and they have the thousand fold right to adore just this type of person with the best
words and honors, the mild, serious, simple-minded and chaste priestly nature and whatever is
related to them.
Um, they are the ones who are the objects of approbation when it comes, when the common
people reveres wisdom.
I'll stop there.
Um, but yeah, I mean like wisdom being just like the territorialized, um, uh, realm of the
common sense of sort of like what we would call common sensical wisdom as juxtaposed against
the de-territorializing force of, um, of, um, of thinking.
And, you know, I think that parenthetical there is really important where it's like,
look, this isn't some detached, bloodless, uh., objective, just sort of, um, correct categorizing,
uh., uh., disimpassioned categorizing of the world.
It is an, uh., an active, eminent, passionate engagement with the world that undoes and remakes
it.
Yeah.
I mean, you, you actually get the terminology in, in the section that I'm talking about.
You actually get the terminology where he says, um., this is against, I, against idealism.
Is this 372 what?
372.
Um, we today are inclined to make the opposite judgment, um, which actually could be equally
wrong, namely that ideas are worse seductresses than our senses for all their cold and anemic
appearances.
And even in spite of this appearance, they've always lived on the blood of the philosopher.
They always consumed his senses.
And even if you will believe us, his heart, these old philosophers were heartless.
Philosophizing was a kind of vampirism.
Uh, looking at these figures, even Spinoza, don't you have a sense of something profoundly
enigmatic and uncanny?
Don't you notice the spectacle that unrolls before you, how they become even paler, how
decentralization is interpreted more and more ideally.
Don't you sense a long concealed vampire in the background who begins with the senses and
is the end left with and leaves mere bones, mere clatter, right?
I mean, in terms of the bloodless, like it's, it's verbatim there, you know, in terms of
the idealists.
I mean, categories, formulas, words, for forgive me, what was left of Spinoza, amor intellectualis
dei, is mere clatter and no more than that.
What is amor, what deus, if there's not a drop of blood in them?
So this isn't, you know, not, not nice things about Spinoza.
Well, pause with that just for a second, because Spinoza's not bloodless, Spinoza's leeched
all the blood out of the ideas, right?
Well, right, right, right.
So in sum, all philosophical idealism to date was something like a disease, unless it was,
as it was in Plato's case, the caution of an over-rich and dangerous health, the fear
of over-powerful senses, the prudence of a prudent Socratic.
Perhaps we moderns are merely not healthy enough to be in need of Plato's idealism, and we
are not afraid of the senses because dot, dot, dot.
Yeah, I like that that turns to Plato there.
Right, because this is, again, it returns to that motif of, like, everything is from either
over-abundance or lack, right?
Like, an over-abundance of life or a feeling of failure in life, and so it's like philosophical
idealism is the same kind of thing.
And in response to Plato there, too, I mean, as a sort of a response to the over-abundance
of the senses and of the over-abundance of the imagination, and there's sort of like a
need of, I don't know, a bloodletting in some kind of way, but Plato's philosophy is hardly
bloodless, and again, like, it's a kind of a vampirism.
It's like diverting the over-abundance of, I mean, I think about, like, machinic desires.
It's sort of coupling that over-abundance of sensuality and channeling it into the conceptual
where it does some wild and fucking crazy stuff.
Well, that's what, that's exactly, you know, the fear of over-powerful senses.
The fear of over-powerful, but it's not, I'm going to return to the image of the vampires,
is that it's not, okay, those senses are over-powering, now we need to domesticate them.
It's more like, I mean, in sort of creating a body without organs, it's like, I'm going to
tap into that over-abundance, that flow of over-abundance is going to move into the conceptual.
Into the conceptual, right.
Into the conceptual.
So the idea is the conceptual ceases to be the anemic hiding from life enterprise that it
is for most idealisms and actually becomes the conduit.
And so that's that sense where it's like, we're not, we're not idealists because we're
not, on the one hand, we're beyond the fucking anemic idealists, but we're not to the point
of the, the cool idealists like Plato, right?
Like, we don't, we don't have that in some ways that machinery has run itself dry.
And, you know, the idealism is simply feeding on itself.
You get little vampires like Spinoza trying to get what little blood there is out of it.
It's again, like, I mean, the philosophical life, I mean, he sort of goes back and forth
and trying to diagnose what kind of life that the philosopher indicates.
Sometimes, you know, like in the case of Kant, it's, it's the intellectual labor or it's
the, the moral labor of just trying to categorize everything.
So you have nice, neat, tidy reasons for following the duty that's already sort of been handed
down to you.
And, you know, when he's talking about in the works of scholarship, sometimes, yeah, it's
just, it's just because I'm tax on, I'm like, I'm just creating taxonomies or with like
the, in the vein of the lawyers, it's just because I want to win and, you know, secondarily
maybe be right.
But that, that one little parenthetical and the one that I just read on the priestly
type, it wasn't actually the parenthetical, it was right before the parenthetical is that,
you know, the philosopher is someone who lives in the thundercloud of the highest problems
and the weightiest responsibilities.
There's a, like, this is a necessity, like Spinoza does this out of a will to power, a need to
exercise that faculty of thinking, finding it wherever, wherever he can, coupling that, that
desire to whatever sort of overabundant flow he can.
Yeah, I mean, that's, that's the part that I like, which is that, I mean, you know, all
philosophy is an expression of will to power, right?
Like, I mean, that's the, you know, that's the simplest general way of saying it, but it's
what does that will to power mean requires a diagnostics of like, okay, so given a certain
philosophy, what kind of life is indicated?
Is it one of becoming or one of being?
And even if it's one of being, is it one of being, I mean, they're even within each of
those categories, there, there are differences as well.
So, you know, it's, it's, you, you have a hermeneutic being set up that can't ever satisfy
itself, right?
Like it can't ever just simply provide a taxonomy.
Well, unless if you use it as a diagnostic, like diagnostic as in like, what, uh, what kind
of life is animating me in so far as I'm trying to perform hermeneutic?
Asking what kind of life it is, right.
Asking what kind of life it is, yeah.
What kind of life asks what kind of life?
Yeah.
Is it provoking and is that, that provocative of a becoming with this sort of taxonomy or
is it, I'm going to nicely, neatly separate them out?
Yeah.
Linnaean taxonomy.
Well, but the idea too, that all philosophy is an expression of the will to power is an
indictment of almost all philosophy.
Yeah.
In so far as philosophy doesn't know that it's an expression or won't recognize, refuses
to recognize that it is an expression of the will to power, that it is an expression of
All these historical, cultural, affective contingencies.
Like that's the one thing that philosophy has attempted to eradicate.
Right.
From its methodology.
In its pursuit of the rigors of science.
Yeah.
It has completely, yeah, sort of disentangled itself from all of the stuff that Nietzsche
finds interesting.
Right.
Well, yeah.
I mean, truth wants to rid itself of historical contingency, you know.
And so philosophy has always wanted to pursue itself, you know, but it never has been.
Right.
I mean, I think that I take that to be the Nietzsche point.
Like it doesn't matter that it's thought it, it thought it could transcend the world.
It never did.
So it was always just an expression of the way of life of its author and the culture and
circumstances surrounding that, you know.
There's an incredible importance too.
There's a function to that sort of thinking of oneself, that matter reflection as well.
And so far is that it's what preserved philosophy, like in its, especially in its infancy.
But even now is that like the thinking that it's doing X, Y, and Z is what allows it the
safe place to do the thing that it's actually doing.
And, you know, this makes me think of the way that, I mean, Nietzsche and Deleuze think
of philosophy as needing to wear the mask of religion for a very long time.
Is that a particular like sort of spin out of, of religion and can only be justified and
only can sort of conduct its operation under the guise of, of religion that's, but it develops
its own, its own style of, of, of life of power that it can't, it can't recognize in itself.
And, and frankly, its capacity to recognize what it's doing is in some ways antithetical
to its capacity to do it.
The masking of contingency that we were just talking about.
I mean, that for Nietzsche is not something that you could simply like correct or alleviate.
Like that's a, that's an irreducible condition of conceptuality and sense, I would say.
Like that's to me, one of the bigger lessons from Truth and Lies is that
concepts abstract and so do sensations that there's not like,
so Nietzsche couldn't be coupled with like the whole affect crowd or the embodiment crowd
that, that where that's the, like the answers are found in the body.
There's still abstraction going on.
There's still.
They just want to flip the, the, the, the binary.
Yeah.
It's like, you know.
Right.
It used to be boo body, hooray reason.
Now it's hooray body, boo reason.
Okay.
So clearly the will to truth is misguided.
And part of the conversation is like, is that a problem?
Is it an ad fact sort of like necessary for the will, the truth to be misguided about what
It's actually trying to do?
Or is there a way, is there perhaps more interestingly a way of thinking like, yeah, the will, the truth
is one form of creation amongst others.
And it's an interesting form of creation.
And what's the danger of the, um, uh, that sort of recognition.
Does that sort of recognition then play its own role in the capacity of that, of the inventive
nature of, of truth, of the will to truth at that level?
Go back and read that genealogy, the, the end of the genealogy of morals there.
You have to remind us about the end of the genealogy of morals.
Well, that's where he, where he talks about the will to truth is, is the sort of telos of
ascetic ideals, um, and of, and of moral thinking when you would sort of think that they're, you
know, opposed things.
But that, that the will to truth is the thing that becomes suspicious.
I mean, that's what, to me, that's what Foucault, you know, his, all of his work took
off from that end, that end of the third book of the genealogy of morals on the will to truth.
I don't think we need to go to the, on the genealogy of morality for that one, because
it's in the section that we just read.
And this is one that I marked out as like something that weighs on me, uh, quite a bit.
So yeah, this is, this is, this is 346.
Our question mark, um, but you do not understand this.
Indeed, people will have trouble understanding us.
We are searching for words, perhaps also for ears.
Who are we anyway?
If we simply call ourselves godless, to use an old expression, or unbelievers, or even
immoralists, we would not think that these words came near to describing us.
We are all of three of them at too advanced a stage for anyone to comprehend, for you to
comprehend, my curious gentlemen, how it feels.
No, no longer with the bitterness and passion of the one who has torn himself away and must
turn his unbelief into another faith, a goal, a martyrdom.
We have become hard boiled, cold, and tough in this realization that the way the world is
not at all divine, even by human standards, it is not rational, merciful, or just.
We know it.
The world we live in is ungodly, immoral, inhuman.
For far too long we have interpreted it falsely and mendaciously, though according to our wish
and will for veneration, that is, according to a need.
For man is a venerating animal, but he is also a mistrustful one, and that the world is
not worth what we thought is about the most certain thing our mistrust has finally gotten
a hold of.
The more mistrust, the more philosophy.
We take care not to claim that the world is worth less.
Indeed, it would seem laughable for us today if man were to aim at inventing values that
were supposed to surpass the value of the real world.
That is exactly what we have turned away from, as from an extravagant aberration of human vanity
and unreason that for long was not recognized as such.
It found its final expression in modern pessimism.
And an older and stronger expression in the teachings of Buddha.
But also Christianity includes it, more doubtfully and ambiguously to be sure, but not for that
reason less seductively.
The whole attitude of man against the world, of man as a world-negating principle, of man
as the measure of values of things, as judge of the world who finally places existence itself
On the scales and finds it too light.
The monstrous stupidity of this attitude has finally dawned upon us, and we are sick of it.
We laugh as soon as we encounter the juxtaposition of man and world, separating by the sublime presumptuousness of the little word and.
But by laughing, haven't we simply taken contempt for man one step further?
And thus, also pessimism, the contempt for that existence which is knowable to us.
Have we not exposed ourselves to the suspicion of an opposition?
An opposition between the world in which, until now, we were at home with our venerations and which we have made it possible for us to endure life.
And another world that we ourselves are, a relentless, fundamental, deepest suspicion concerning ourselves
that is steadily gaining more and more control over us, over us Europeans,
and that could easily confront coming generations with the terrible either-or.
Either abolish your venerations or yourselves.
The latter would be nihilism.
But would not the former also be nihilism?
That is our question mark.
I feel like this is something that I've been grappling with for a while.
To put it in the question of the three metamorphoses and thus speaks the Zarathustra,
the movement from the camel that carries inherited duty, burdened conceptions,
to the lion that attacks and critiques those conceptions,
and then the movement to the child that creates dances, has the gay artistic response to this.
This seems to be, the camel is nowhere to be found in what I just read,
but the hinge point between the lion and the child seems to be the essence of this question mark.
On the one hand, we recognize the constructedness of all of this and a certain sort of ridiculousness of man as the venerating animal
that needs to find its truth, that needs to find its assurity, its footing.
And then, yeah, also the necessity of something like that for creation, because there is a dangerous path.
This is like Nietzsche seeing the possibility of his way of thinking as slipping into a kind of nihilism,
a nihilism of that creativity.
Yeah, that it simply carried the contempt for man one step further.
Like, when, you know, like, are we not, are we not a symptom of the problem?
Yeah.
You know, in wanting to push past this sort of silly idea of man and world.
Yeah, in that sense of nihilism, I mean, like, he's so concerned with health here and, you know, and will,
and he sort of posits faith as what generates, you know, a facsimile of will when there's actually just weakness.
Oh, with the subsequent stuff like, so like, yeah, like faith, faith becomes the conditions, faith and metaphysics and positivism.
But it puts you in a bit of a catch-22.
Yeah, it totally does.
Where you have to be, where you have to be, allow yourself to be duped.
And I know I've developed this suspicious, like, I've been duped too many fucking times.
And so now I'm just an eternal skeptic.
And it's like, guess what?
Being a skeptic is its own, can become its own article of faith.
Well, that's right.
And it has its own nihilism built into it.
Yes.
You know.
So abolish your reverences, you know.
Including your reverence to irreverence.
Right.
Well, what the fuck is left, right?
It's a way of thinking antagonism, I think, beyond, like, the dialectic.
In that, you know, you follow a path long enough and it feels like it circles back around.
But not because there was some kind of opposition.
Well, I think it's more just that there isn't an answer.
Right?
Like, it's just, it's not a question of, when you say what the fuck is left, it's like.
Mm-hmm.
Life.
It's not a question of, it's not a question of an alternative position.
It's just a question of, you know, like, there's a series of moves on the board.
It's not a question of finding the next move on the board, but of, like, cycling through those different moves, you know.
So there's, you know, five possible ways of being, you know, or 25.
It doesn't really matter what the number is, but it's not about finding a 26.
It's just, I mean, what we do is we just move through those 25 in different ways at different times.
So, like, you know, the strike did one thing to you, the physical thing did one thing to move.
Like, and so we just cycle through those different moments, and they're more or less generative, more or less productive, but there's none of them are an answer.
And we can't live in any of them.
No.
And I find that my, the speed of my thinking goes so much faster than the speed of my affects or the speed of my, like, my bodily condition.
So, you know, the aphorism that we're reading a little bit earlier, the one that kind of inaugurated a lot of this conversation about, like, there are two forms of life.
The one that seeks being, seeks rest, seeks respite, and the one that is a symptom of an overabundance of life.
And, you know, I'm completely with you.
Like, I mean, it's like, just give me some motherfucking peace and being and stillness and respite from chaos.
It's totally Christian.
It's like, I want to die.
Totally Christian.
Yeah, it is.
I want, well, what it is, I want to be alleviated from the momentary suffering.
And then you think about it long enough, and it becomes, you realize, yeah, I want to die.
That's, that's all, that's really all it is, because it's like, all right, what are the moments?
Well, wait, this is the fantasy before you go to bed.
What are the things that are pressing upon me right now?
How do I rearticulate my world?
How do I come in with my authorial sort of intent and reorganize things so that I don't have these things pressing upon me?
Right.
And that's, of course, its own, like, self-perpetuating line of thought, where it's like, now I fixed everything in my life.
What do I do now?
I guess I'm just, like, ready to die, right?
I'm going to snap my fingers, all of these things go away, and now I start living?
Now it's like, now there's nothing fucking to do.
There's nothing to do.
But now, but now the thing is, is that conceptually speaking, I'm back to now giving me the overabundance.
Give me the, you know, I want to live in this life of perpetual upheaval, but my fucking body's not there, right?
Whatever, like, whatever chemical response, like, they didn't follow that train of thought that fast.
They're still like, strike, strike, strike.
Fucking, fucking biology is stuck in resentment, man.
Yeah.
My body is happy at being angry.
I mean, maybe one of the things he's saying is that, like, we're all compensating for certain inadequacies, perceived inadequacies and insecurities.
Everybody's compensating all the time.
So I guess it's a matter of not letting those compensations or that process, like, sediment into, into resentment, I suppose.
But as soon as you think of it as a compensation, then you've already marked out the guilty line.
Like, compensating for what?
Well, some failure of an ideal, right?
And so for that to not let that spill into resentment is to forget that resentment was the only thing that was able to make the differentiation.
Yeah, so in a certain sense, the only way that you could act from overabundance is if you're just not aware that you're acting from overabundance.
Because the moment that you become aware that it's overabundance, it becomes now a lack.
So it's just, yeah, so it's consciousness is the fucking problem.
Like, just go do shit.
Yeah.
Unless if you think, I mean, and this is the other thing that I've been working with so much, is, like, we just have to reconfigure the, like, reconfigure the coordinates of consciousness.
And not think, like, it's the privileged place, but also not shit on it, either.
Yeah.
It's that it's one actor among others that adds one sort of differentiating sort of thing.
It's like, it's like, you can't get rid of it.
You certainly can't privilege it.
So it needs to be able to be, I mean, it has to be made multiple.
I don't even, I don't understand how in Nietzsche there would even be a binary between conscious and unconscious.
Because everything, your entire being is mobilized by libidinal, non-conscious factors.
So your consciousness is simply an expression of a purpose or a drive.
That's right.
That is always, not even unknown to you, but unknowable and outside of the contours of the knowable.
And so one particularly strange side effect of that contour of the bodily and the mental is that it has this, like, it burps out words like I, right?
And it's like, oh, that's a strange side effect, you know?
It's just like what, you know, carbon dioxide makes me burp and consciousness makes me say I.
Like, that's just, you know, that's just one of them.
And the I is a compensation.
The I is a compensation for complexity.
Well, see, I wouldn't even say it's a compensation, though.
Yeah, compensation is the, yeah.
I mean, I see why you're reticent on compensation.
Yeah.
It's making up for a deficit.
As opposed to, like, hey, here's a way of celebrating.
But why couldn't it be making up for too much complexity?
Why can't you just flip the, like, compensating for an overabundance?
Making up?
You know.
For, suggest that, like.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, there's, I mean, I see what you're saying, like, with the sense of an overabundance, right?
But still, we're saying, like, if one has to compensate or make up for an overabundance, that presumes that the overabundance is secondary to a being.
That there is a being that is now overflowing.
And then now that becomes the problem.
But if what life is, is just simply overabundance, and then strange delineations afterwards that market into I, you, other, right?
Then it's sort of like the, what's happening in which direction there?
Yeah.
I mean, if you, instead of compensating, you think of it as emergence.
You know, it's just like, it's a, it's a, it's a, consciousness is an emergent phenomena of the complex, you know, given a certain amount of complexity of shit interacting, consciousness happens.
Which I think is actually, that is the sort of, you know, understanding of consciousness in, in, uh.
Like neurosciences.
In the neurosciences today.
Like, you get it, it's like, you get to up to something like a billion neurons interacting with each other, and this is just a, like, side effect.
Yeah.
But everything, everything is still framed, I mean, at least from my understanding, it's still framed through the lens of utility.
So, like, all of these are adapt, these are adaptations that are, that are for our survival.
How very English of you.
Whereas I don't think that's what Nietzsche is saying.
I don't think, I don't think that's what Nietzsche is saying.
That's not what he says at all.
It's the opposite.
Utility is, utility is the concept that's going to kill us.
Nietzsche is the one who says how very English of you.
Yes.
Right, right.
In that, like, his, his reading of the English genealogists are, that they're all too utilitarian, in that you begin with the telos of survival, and then you're like, all right, now I'm going to develop or adapt traits that are going to further survival.
I mean, you know, in the section that we read, he's like, what the hell does life care about survival?
It's got a different symptom.
Oh, crazy overabundance.
Go to a fucking jungle.
Like, yes, individual critters are concerned with something maybe like survival, but that is just an overflowing, overabundant expression of infinite sets of powers, right?
Dude, I'm in South Carolina in April.
There is fucking plant sex, plant sperm on every surface, everywhere.
It's just, yeah, it's just, or you like, even think about Derrida in Plato's Pharmacy, like this, like the, the wanton spilling of, of liquid sperm, whatever.
Like, that, that's, at least his sort of reading of, of Plato and a certain metaphysical impulse is to like tidy it all up, put it in the right places, make sure it's like going, you know, like, it's like, it's all legitimate.
It's coding everything.
It's just everywhere.
And it's like, well, when it goes over there, this bouts up, and this one goes over there.
It's like fucking lungs, and it gives me the ergos of the alos, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose.
And it gives me the ergos of the alos.
I start spewing stuff out of my nose.
I start spewing stuff out of my nose, and it gives me the ergos of the alos, and it gives me the ergos of the alos, and it gives me the ergos of the alos, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose, and I start spewing stuff out of my nose.